This is the first part of the 3 videos I am going to make
explaining each plan of the new subscription of Real Madrid.
com I start with the free license that has the benefit of having your own
license that you can save in your wallet and such digital and you have
access to real madrid online the club TV basically you have a 5 discount in
the club store also send you a message or an email every week more or less
as a summary of what has happened in the entity and contests and such that
if you get it then you get this card it is digital it is not physical you
do not have to pay anything and in this plan you
can subscribe everyone as it is free.